i've got to get myself situated first
because i've recently just moved as well
it was a new place is good it was an
interesting uh moving experience mostly
because
of all the [ __ ] that uh sydney has built
up over the years
okay so we hired the same moving company
right so
uh so there's this main guy and he knows
that we're youtubers because he moved uh
he moved all the trash all the trash day
stuff right um i don't think he was
prepared
like he knew that we were anime fans
right but i don't think he was prepared
for some of the stuff that sydney had uh
like just within her closet yeah and
i remember so poor man yeah before
before
so before before they do the move they
also have to like scout the place just
to see what they have to move and how
many trucks they have to rent out and
sydney sydney was just like you know
what i know the stuff i i know my room's
a bit of a bit of a nuclear like
wasteland right now you know i'm gonna
clean it up a bit right so what she does
is she uh takes off all like the lewd
posters off the wall right she's like
i'm gonna i'm cleaning up my room right
no she's not gonna notice cleaning up
clear cleaning up my room so she takes
off all the loot posters thinking she's
got a job done i've got nothing to worry
about what she forgets
right is there's no posters on the wall
but there's just a massive pile of sex
toys in the corner
that she just somehow forgot about
you really know how numb she is to that
kind of [ __ ] now right where it's like
oh yeah there's nothing wrong with that
right it's just pushing around
it's the [ __ ] of the round
right there and it's the 10 kilogram
boobs that are just uh lying on the
floor so she forgets to hide that but
she takes off the slightly lewd posters
off the wall
this is distasteful
so the guy opens the door and is greeted
by just the 10 kilogram boobs that are
just sitting on her desk
that she somehow just forgot about
absolutely
he probably wanted to like get out of
there yeah
and uh yeah so
after after we get everything packed up
obviously he like they they hired
different people uh so he's seen all
this before but obviously his employees
haven't seen this right oh no and uh so
they have to they have to pack
everything up right and um so
uh how it was they packed everything up
there were about like four men just
loading loading stuff into the two
trucks that we had uh sydney stayed
behind
um sydney stayed behind to clean up the
place after we'd all
we were all driving to our new place to
unpack everything um and i sat with them
in one of the vans and i sat with them
with two of them and two of them weren't
the main guys they were just one of
their employees yeah and it was just
like it was like a good 15 20 minutes of
silence right
and uh we were just driving along and
each and the guy next to me just goes
so interesting stuff you got there
and i'm just
i'm just like oh oh my god and i know so
it's like i'm starting to [ __ ]
explain this [ __ ] right so it's like you
know this is just you know we're
youtubers and uh the room that that room
that room you know that room that's
that's not my room how do you explain
that [ __ ] though that's like trying to
explain what b board is on 4chan right
it's like uh yeah so there's a lot of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] here but don't worry
about it it's completely fine like yeah
yeah you get used to it when i showed
them all the [ __ ] cosplays i had they
were like what the [ __ ]
why do you have so many costumes why is
there so many dresses i don't know
that's my job
what can i say you know well what's
worse to say if it's your job or if it's
your hobby
the guy walked in my room was like yes
you're single huh
i'm glad cindy was there because
if it was just me sorting this out i
can't how do i explain that how the [ __ ]
do i explain that so yeah i live i live
with a fiancee and she uh collects uh
sex toys and reviews them on our youtube
channel and they're just like yeah sure
review sure yeah sure
it's not even the worst part because
after after have this like uh half an
hour explanation uh explain to them what
we did and just you know just just
explain in the situation so they
understand so we get to the house and uh
so they start unloading stuff you know
first goes the bed and then all like the
other boxes and then the big stuff and
then i had scheduled the gas guy to come
on the same day because you know we've
got a ton of gas maximize you know min
maxing min maxing moving yep um so i get
a phone call from the gas guy as every
as everyone's coming in
um packing unloading all the stuff into
the house i'm like oh i'm about to come
over is that cool and i'm like great
perfect i'm here right now just come
right in
um so he comes in checks the gas thing
turns it on
does the check everything's perfect and
as he's as he's about to walk down the
stairs guess what pops up it's the 10
kilogram boobs right in front of him
that the guy just like [ __ ] presents
with him on a silver platter and the guy
wasn't inside
wasn't it inside of like a box or
anything like that yeah it was it was
inside a box the box the packaging which
is just an anime girl with her breasts
out right because this thing this thing
doesn't need to go in a box it is its
own box it's it's just boobs that is 10
kilograms the box is big enough by
itself so he just he stops they both
stop the gas guy looks at him uh looks
at him
looks down at the box
looks at me and he goes
oh very important i'm just like did he
really yeah yeah
so he's like yes yes it is
the guy said what if the guy was like oh
i got one of those
oh [ __ ] you've got the new mother [ __ ]
there's a model right there pog
so yeah
yeah i'm just i just phone city up
afterwards i'm just like why did why did
you give me this job i should be doing
one cleaning up you should be the one
handling it with this it's really
necessary to keep with that yeah
also did it need to go in the box that
had all the loot [ __ ] in front of it
like you couldn't have just put it in
like the moving box so i i i we let the
movers pack a lot cause what i did with
all my loot [ __ ] is that i packed it in
a box separately before the moving
people came so they had no idea of all
the curse [ __ ] i have in my house
i try to pack as much stuff as i could
but there's too much stuff yeah i just
cause when they pack stuff i just lost
track of everything i was like i don't
know which box everything's in yeah i
try to like i try to like help them and
like try to keep track of everything and
then like about two hours in you realize
i don't know where anything is anymore
yeah and so like even like a month after
i was like which box is that one
specific thing i need him i tear up in
all the boxes can't find it i'm like
well i'm [ __ ] yeah yeah like i still
haven't found my wireless headphones uh
which is somewhere in one of the boxes
um i i like you forget about the little
items that you kind of need in
day-to-day life
um until you're staring at about 20
boxes in front of you and you realize
that oh this this one thing is in one of
these boxes i guess how does that happen
every time i swear like it doesn't
matter who i ask how far they're moving
how much stuff they have every move
items just like
go into like some donnie darko [ __ ]
happens where it just like disappears
into a void on the way it's like because
like you you look at it because i had
that as well where i was like okay i'm
missing like two or three items at least
yeah i went back to the old house
obviously not there ring up the moving
company they say they don't have it i'm
like well then where the [ __ ] did it go
you're not gonna tell me it's in one of
these boxes
because you open it all up and still not
there yeah yeah i'm like what did i do
with it where did it go
i missed moving as a student you just
had like two suitcases yeah yeah exactly
right like you just chuck everything
away you don't need because the thing is
when you're moving when you have like an
apartment and stuff you just forget how
much [ __ ] just is hidden yeah so so you
probably was such a nightmare yeah you
packed the big [ __ ] and you're like oh
i'm like 80 done then somehow you add
another three hours of packing on top of
that because there's so just so much
[ __ ] that's just accumulated
randomly i was surprised how much [ __ ]
was in my kitchen
yeah yeah yeah i thought my kitchen was
like two two boxes three boxes yeah yeah
it was like 15 boxes just kitchen [ __ ]
like how how is this what
why do i own so many spoons and plates
what is this
i didn't know i owned that much [ __ ]
yeah i'm like why do i have like four
different types of plates i don't know i
only use one it's because you like go
deep into like covers that you open like
once every like a couple of months and
he's like oh okay i didn't realize i had
17 bottles of [ __ ] dishwashing liquid
just like sitting back there yeah yeah
oh dude man getting rid of all the
cardboard after moving was
don't talk to me about that don't talk
to me about 19 000 i i probably had a
japanese forest worth of cardboard in my
apartment at one point luckily the
service we ordered they took all the
cardboard with them because they
unpacked it all for us
but doesn't that doesn't that service
cost like 10 grand yeah but we were
sponsored yeah know yeah [ __ ] well nice
nice for some nice for some i just
haven't reported
i just can't in good faith pay 10 grand
for them to move my stuff oh no if i
didn't get sponsored by i wouldn't pay
for it i just yeah like the one that
they charged me like two i think two
grand yeah which i was like
okay yeah okay that makes sense i guess
it's a full day of work it's a full tank
it's a truck you're like talking to
yourself out of it two days of work
you're throwing away stuff too yeah that
makes sense
okay it makes it somewhere
somewhere
company someone was moving into my
building and it was like the whole place
had been like taken over by them there
was like 15 of them yeah yeah like like
the elevator and like the outsiders
no wonder they cost like 10 grand they
they've got the whole goddamn japanese
workforce here doing their stuff
they really they really are like i don't
know why i guess they're really prideful
of their company or something but like
they love plastering their logo
all over the [ __ ] i mean it works it
seems like a [ __ ] yeah it seems like
a military operation yeah so it's like
that scene from the anime where they
called the sdf they're like oh [ __ ]
get the sdf down here man this this [ __ ]
this is a real journey
it's like oh [ __ ] here we go to be fair
i understand man if you've got a family
you've got kids and [ __ ] and you're
doing pretty well for yourself i get it
i [ __ ] trying to move with my kids like
i would like i would not want to be in
my situation that i was in plus kids
yeah yeah i understand that it's like
yeah just bring in the [ __ ] sas bring
in the marines yeah yeah get bringing
john cena to do it like i i do not want
or especially if you were you know like
you know in your 60s 70s oh god yeah
it's like yeah just [ __ ]